- It's not salty, it's not
bitter, it's not oh mommy.
- Have you ever put a
Candy Corn in your mouth?
- I don't want to put it in my mouth.
- I don't think he has,
cause he doesn't even
know what it is.
- Boo. Just kidding, Candy Corn.
The sweet herald of spooky times to come
or a seasonal blight? It's debatable.
- I'm pro-Candy Corn because
I have joy in my life.
- And I'm against Candy Corn.
- I think Candy Corn is the bomb.
- I think Candy Corn sucks.
- Candy Corn is the dumbest candy.
- Candy Corn is the most fun candy.
- Wow God what do I even
love about Candy Corn.
- Exactly.
- Candy Corn is the perfect holiday treat.
- It's the first thing that
you see that your like,
ah fall is here.
- Well that's because my
opponent is living in California
being ignorant to the rest of the world.
- I think you could have
Candy Corn just sitting out
for three months and it'd still be okay.
- That's not the sign of a good candy.
- Do you even dress up on Halloween?
- Yeah.
- What is this costume?
- This isn't Halloween.
- You didn't wear a
costume, to this debate
cause you're not fun, but
I am and so is candy corn.
- It's got a very distinct look.
- You can say that about any candy.
- Really?
- M&MS, Skittles they
look exactly the same,
if I gave you a bowl of M&MS and Skittles
right here, you would reach
in, eat some and be like
(squeals)
- Candy Corn is so special,
that only once a year, it shows
up to bring joy into
the lives of children.
Chocolate is lying to
everyone, it's like "oh I'm a
Halloween chocolate, I'm
a Christmas chocolate --"
- I'm not gonna sit
here and listen to you.
- This isn't pretending to be anything.
- Slander chocolate!
- Do you know that
Americans eat nine billion
pieces of Candy Corn every year.
- Maybe 32 million pieces of Candy Corn
are thrown away.
- That's statistically
not even a big number
out of nine billion.
- [Man] What--
- What about Candy Corn, is
so horrific that it has to go?
It's just millions of people
like it, millions of people
have fun when they have Candy
Corn on Halloween every year.
That's terrible?
Have you ever had a
debate before Michelle?
(laughs)
- The fact is that you can spend your time
doing something better, if
you're trying to eat candy--
- Lies, clearly lies.
- [Man] You can get better candy.
- It's like eating a candle.
- An edible candle, you're
telling me you wouldn't eat that?
- No.
- I think that'd be fire.
- What do you think is
worse then Candy Corn?
- [Man] Like--
- Literally nothing.
- Wait literally nothing, exactly
it's the bottom of the barrel.
- Kids are crying all
over American who get
Candy Corn in their bags.
- And where are your scientific polls?
- I surveyed the group of
kids that I trick-or-treated
with growing up.
- Did you know them beforehand?
- Yeah of course we did.
- That's a sourcing issue,
she is sourcing her data.
- It's a candy modeled after a vegetable,
you realize that right?
- You know how many jobs
there are in this country
because people produce corn, you're saying
you don't like farmers?
- No, I love corn I just don't think
it needs a candy tribute.
- Okay you want me to
eat it? Look I'll eat...
It's like eating Indian clay.
- I do have a little bit of a stomachache.
- It's making you sick.
- It's not.
- Haters are gonna continue
to hate, no matter what.
- Anybody who ends a debate
with haters gonna hate or
that's just your opinion, has
obviously lost the debate.
- Final thoughts, Candy Corn
is the perfect seasonal candy.
- You're doing the perfect
season, a complete disservice.
- Candy Corn, much like,
gimme a second goddamn you.
- I throttled my opponent
so heavily, she can't--
- Oh my--
come up with a closing statement.
- I'm going to kill you Alvis!
- Walk into the club
like a G and you're like,
fuck it's Halloween,
what's happening can you
throw Snickers in the
air? No you make it rain.
- Ow. I've been injured.
- [Woman] You see.